In the near future, cash could become
obsolete, and your phone could completely
replace your wallet. Mobile payments,
which are already commonplace in
numerous countries worldwide, are
steadily gaining traction. In China's
biggest cities, ninety-two percent of people use WeChat Pay or Alipay, the market's main
competitors, and mobile payments are
accepted by restaurants, retailers, street
vendors, and even taxis. More broadly, in
2018, the mobile money industry completed
1.3 billion dollars of transactions
daily across ninety countries. This
underscores a shift toward a cashless
society dominated by electronic banking
and digital finance, where physical
transactions like bartering are
virtually non-existent. Proponents for a
cashless system believe that digital
money increases convenience and could
reduce robbery and counterfeiting, while
opponents argue that it endangers
privacy and hurts disadvantaged
communities that rely on cash. And while
many of the long-term consequences of
cashlessness remain to be seen, the
movement towards a cashless society
seems highly likely, if not inevitable.